The Star Wars saga is one of the best-known
in the entire history of cinema, as a fan-favorite
of every generation – and a brand new trilogy
aiming to bring even more fans into the fold.
But you would be surprised to know just how
many scenes director George Lucas originally
meant to include in his space epic.
Scenes that could have turned out to be completely
unforgettable, if they hadn’t wound up on
the cutting room floor.
Here are Screenrant’s 10 Star Wars Movie
Scenes You’ve Never Seen.
Greedo Never Learns
No Star Wars prequel take more heat than the
Phantom Menace, but fans missed out on one
original trilogy cameo that was guaranteed
to cause some controversy.
After Anakin wins the podrace, Qui-Gon finds
the boy fighting with a young Rodian who claims
he cheated.
When the kids are split up, the final reveal
comes - it's no random Rodian, but a young
Greedo, the same bounty hunter who would learn
the hard way that Han always shoots first...
Depending on who you ask.
A Proud Smuggler
The assault on the shield generator station
in Return of the Jedi always seemed a bit
rushed, and with good reason: the original
version had Han and his team taking out a
Squad of stormtroopers before being ambushed
and captured.
But the real shame is that audiences never
got to hear what could have been another classic
Han Solo one liner.
When cornered and accused of being "Rebel
Scum," the Corellian smuggler takes genuine
offense to the term, as only he can.
Tosche Station
No die-hard Star Wars fan will ever forget
the first time Luke mentioned he’d be making
a trip to Tosche station for some all-important
power converters.
But the location was originally going to be
shown when Luke rushed to tell his friends
about the space battle visible over Tattooine.
The scene also introduced Luke’s best friend
Biggs Darklighter, long before the two were
reunited before the attack on the Death Star.
At the time, Biggs was still training to be
an Imperial pilot before defecting to the
Rebellion.
Wampa Troubles
Freezing cold isn't the only danger on Hoth,
and the Empire Strikes Back opens with Luke
finding out how much damage a wild Wampa can
really do.
But the massive creatures were originally
going to be shown as a headache for the entire
Rebel base, with the troops managing to trap
them in a single room in Echo Base.
When the Empire breaks in and the heroes flee,
C-3PO has the bright idea to remove the warning
sign, leading one trooper into a bloody end.
Apparently, the droid doing something clever,
funny and helpful was deemed too out of character,
and the scene was cut.
Seeds of The Rebellion
It's not hard to guess why yet another political
subplot was cut out of Revenge of the Sith,
but we would bet most fans would have liked
to see Padme and Bail Organa start to form
the future Rebel Alliance in the senate's
back rooms.
Especially working with a young Mon Mothma
years before she would lead the resistance
and brief Luke Skywalker on the Death Star's
weakness.
Considering how many extra subplots *didn't*
get cut, this one seems like a missed opportunity,
and a clever way of linking the prequels and
original trilogy.
Endor’s Fate
If you've ever wondered why the second Death
Star didn't just blow up Endor's forest moon
and take out Han Solo and Leia once and for
all, a deleted scene has the answer.
The Emperor actually gave that exact order,
demanding the battlestation destroy the moon
if its shields were ever sabotaged.
It's hard to know why the scene was taken
out - it would have added a ticking clock
to the entire Ewok battle, and the Commander's
mixed feelings over killing his own troops
along with the enemy showed not *every* Imperial
officer was completely evil.
Luke’s New Lightsaber
We know what you're thinking: there's no way
that a scene showing Luke as a full-fledged
Jedi Knight, building his own Lightsaber could
be cut out of Return of the Jedi, right?
Wrong.
Before he sent his droids into Jabba's palace,
Luke's new look was originally going to be
revealed as he put the finishing touches on
his green saber.
The scene makes his plan to smuggle the weapon
through security a bit clearer, but his second
reveal to Jabba the Hutt was deemed to be
a better one.
We'll let the fans decide that one.
C-3PO Saves The Day
It's no secret George Lucas strayed into creepy
territory with the implied love between Luke
and Leia, but eventually played their kiss
in the Empire Strikes Back as a joke, when
the characters were revealed to be brother
and sister ("he's my brother!" clip from the
end of Jedi).
But a deleted scene took things much, much
farther.
Not only is the scene a more romantic one,
it shows that both siblings were genuinely
attracted to each other, and on the verge
of a passionate kiss before C-3PO interrupts.
Some claim the deleted scene is proof Lucas
still hadn't decided the two were twins when
the movie was filmed, and frankly, that's
the only explanation for this scene that doesn't
make our skin crawl.
You Only Die Twice
General Grievous may have gotten more laughs
than screams, but the Jedi-killer's original
introduction in Episode 3 showed he was no
joke, executing a Jedi named Shaak Ti with
her own lightsaber.
The lighthearted hand signals between Obi-Wan
and Anakin that followed her death showed
the scene was a bit too awkward to work, but
Lucas was determined to kill the Jedi on screen.
So determined, he also filmed her death at
the hands of Anakin when he first turned to
the Dark Side - which also wound up on the
cutting room floor.
Guess Who’s Coming to Dinner?
The budding romance between Anakin Skywalker
and Padme in Attack of the Clones wasn't a
hit with every fan, but George Lucas originally
planned to spend even more time on their courtship.
Deleted scenes take the pair to visit Padme's
parents and older sister, who can't help but
notice the young Jedi's affection.
It’s hard to say this dating drama is really
a fit for the series at all, but in the end,
the director probably decided introducing
characters who’d never know what happened
to their grandchildren raised more questions
than it answered.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite deleted scenes
or abandoned subplots in the Star Wars series?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.